estas imágenes fueron publicadas en las
redes sociales un dron detecta un tanque
ruso y lo destruye con bombas
este otro vídeo fue tomado hace unas
semanas en el área de mico life cerca
del mar negro los ucranianos han estado
usando drones improvisados en todo el
país el ejército tiene su propia unidad
de drones creada por un grupo de civiles
hace varios años
[Música]
son personas realmente diferentes
estudiantes científicos empresarios
creemos que nuestros drones son muy
útiles en esta guerra estamos cambiando
las reglas reviews fuentes
los drones son los ojos del ejército
ucraniano además de imágenes de satélite
dando una imagen más clara de las tropas
rusas en el terreno este puede llevar 5
kilogramos de explosivos una imagen
resume la eficiencia de la táctica del
drone muestra una columna de tanques
rusos avanzando sobre kiev a la unidad
de aerosvit que se le atribuye a la
destrucción de tanques y el bloqueo de
esta columna que los obligó a retroceder
find encontramos la columna de tanques
enviamos esta información a ciertos
servicios detuvimos la cabeza de la
columna estaban desmoralizados la
ventaja que tienen los rusos es su
cantidad somos más inteligentes
es difícil saber qué tan determinante es
la unidad de drones para el ejército
pero se ha convertido en un símbolo de
los civiles ucranianos para defender a
su país